NARRATOR:
This is the Shark Tank,
where hopeful entrepreneurs
get a once-in-a-lifetime chance
to pitch the sharks...
I'm a fireman,
and I design tools.
NARRATOR: ...In hopes
of getting an investment
to start, grow,
or save their businesses.
What if I told you
you could charge your phone
from a pot of boiling water?
Wow.
The entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for...
Or they'll walk away
with nothing.
What's the profit?
How does it work?
The profit's tough.
Tough?
You must be kidding me.
NARRATOR: If the sharks
hear a great idea...
We're projecting to be
in the range
of about $2 million
next year.
♪ Ching-ching! ♪
NARRATOR: ...They're ready
to invest using their own money.
There's many
venture-capital firms.
There's only one Shark Tank.
NARRATOR: And they're willing
to fight each other
for a piece of the action.
Would you go 40%?
No.
20%/20%?
No, this is not a company.
It's a product.
Oh, Lord.
I don't care what
Mr. Cuban says about this.
And if you want to step in
and take my $75,000
at a different price,
go ahead and do it.
what are you gonna do?
I'm suffering,
I'm suffering!
NARRATOR:
Who are the sharks?
They're self-made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Daymond John is
a fashion and branding expert
who grew
his homemade clothing line
into the globally recognized
fashion brand fubu,
with over $6 billion
in retail sales to date.
Robert Herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold his first internet
companies for over $350 million.
Lori Greiner, the queen of QVC,
holds over 100 patents and
has launched over 300 products,
grossing over a half a billion
dollars in retail sales.
And Mark Cuban,
notorious billionaire
entrepreneur, tech guru,
and the outspoken owner
of the NBA's Dallas Mavericks.
First into the tank
is an innovative service
to connect students
and teachers.
Hello, sharks.
My name is Taylor Robinson,
and I'm from Dallas, Texas.
I'm the proud owner
of Taylor Robinson Music,
and we're here today
to raise $100,000 in exchange
for 10% equity in our company.
Now, I'm a musician.
I've been playing guitar
for over 20 years,
and I started this company while
in my high-school garage band.
And from those meager roots,
we've come to revolutionize
the way people find and hire
private music instructors
all over the country.
Now, it's unfortunate,
but music programs get cut
from schools every day,
leaving parents wondering...
[ chord plays ]
♪ Where do I go ♪
[ laughs ]
♪ For music lessons?
They often look
on websites they can't trust.
Or they'll look for flyers
at instrument stores,
but they won't know
who they're getting.
They won't know if their
instructors are any good,
if they're a good match
for them,
or if they're even safe
to let into their homes.
Taylor Robinson music says...
[ chord plays ]
♪ Don't find your teachers
in chat rooms ♪
That's gross.
[ laughter ]
Taylor Robinson music
solves these problems
and a whole lot more.
Here's how it works.
Students use our website
or mobile app
by entering in their zip code
and the instrument
that they want to learn.
When they do, they can search
through literally thousands
of Taylor Robinson music
screened and approved
instructors in their area.
They can read reviews.
They can see their specialties.
They can look at maps.
They can even see schedules.
When they pick the instructor
perfect just for them,
they then use our site to
schedule and book the lessons.
And Taylor Robinson music
gets a small commission.
[ chord plays ]
♪ Cha-ching! ♪
♪ Move it on up ♪
[ laughs ]
Sharks, we've had a lot
of success to date,
but we need your expertise
and your help
to crank this thing to 11, so...
[ guitar music plays ]
♪ Who's ready to rock? ♪
With Taylor Robinson music.
GREINER: Yay.
[ applause ]
HERJAVEC: Very good.
very good, ladies.
Whoo!
Beautiful voices.
Thank you so much.
♪ Taylor,
do we make any money? ♪
We've made over $2.5 million
in the past five or six years.
♪ Ching-ching! ♪
[ laughter ]
The last 12 months?
Last year,
we made $450,000.
This year, we're about
to make $550,000.
What's the profit?
How does it work?
Profit's tough.
Tough?
Yeah, the profit numbers
are tough.
We've made only about $40,000
a year in profit,
and that's why we're here today.
oh.
Why?
Why? Because we have two costs
that are messing up our margins.
The first is the cost
of costumer acquisition.
The second is the cost
of operation.
♪ How are we gonna fix that? ♪
[ laughs ]
ROBINSON:
Well, lucky for you,
I've already fixed
one of those problems.
We have been becoming experts
in local search-engine
optimization.
This is the most effective way
for us to find our students,
but it's still costing us
$33 to acquire each customer.
So, what is your margin
when you do a sale?
An average lesson --
half-hour lesson costs $23.
And what do you make
off of that?
$9.
Wow.
Yeah, 38% margin,
but we're only bringing in
maybe $3 or $2.
Mm.
What we're looking here
to do is raise some money
to finish our enterprise system
to automate a lot of the systems
that we're having to do
manually.
How many instructors
do you have on the site
in total?
Right now, we have
4,000 instructors.
GREINER: How are you
vetting these people?
They're going
into people's homes.
That's the question.
Yes, so what --
now, we're dealing --
safety is number one.
We're looking
at background checks, criminal,
sex offenders, social security.
And that's your overhead cost
that you were talking about
that were killing you,
right?
That --
you do
all that screening?
That's part of the system
that could use automation.
Well --
now, the real situation
is that most instructors are
professional touring musicians.
Our teachers are
not just academics.
We're not the old lady
with the ruler.
I'm a professional musician.
I did this in between tours,
and we're specifically looking
to hire a recording artist.
So there's a coolness
factor, right?
Exactly.
So that leads to,
who are the stars, right?
Brag. You're on national
television, Taylor. Brag.
All right, so, the guitarist
for Earth wind & fire
or -- or a lot of people
that are on "American Idol"
that come second or, you know,
somebody who's
on "America's got talent."
so you have them
on your list?
Absolutely.
And are they actively teaching?
Yeah, they're hugely popular.
So, they're doing it
for 23 bucks?
Right,
so they're offering --
Robert, I know that
you see them on television.
I know that you know the names
of the bands,
but I'm telling you,
these guys do not have as much
money as you think they do.
Taylor, I took guitar lessons
from a master.
I mean, the guy played
with Aerosmith.
He was getting
about 90 bucks an hour
'cause everybody
wanted to use him.
Is there variability?
Absolutely.
I am a premium guy,
and I want to go on your site.
Can I set my price?
Can -- absolutely not.
Whoa, that's a big mistake
in your model.
Instructors cannot
set their price.
O'LEARY:
Well, why do you care?
Why don't you just take
your percentage
off whatever my market rate is?
Our software can't handle
each instructor
having a different rate,
but we're very close
to finishing the software
to do that.
You must be kidding me.
We will be able to do that
with a very small, one-time fee,
about $50,000.
We'll be able to not only make
those adjustments.
We will be able
to simplify payroll.
I would've preferred you
came into the Shark Tank
with all of that worked out
and you just needed to pour
gasoline on a proven model.
That's not what we got here.
Okay.
You should've fixed this stuff
and then come in here saying,
"I fixed it all.
I need $100,000
to pour gasoline on it."
I would've been interested.
I'm not interested in this.
I'm out.
Sir, what we've got here
is sales.
Right.
We've got a proven interest,
a massive proven interest
in our --
in our product
and in our service.
You're very, very close.
There's -- there's a lot
of holes in the Dike,
and you've identified
where they all are.
right.
But putting the putty in there
or putting a finger in there,
that's a little bit
more complicated
than I think
you're giving it credit for.
Sure.
Because if it goes wrong...
Where are you?
You're back in the same hole.
Sure, sure.
Right, and so you're
a little bit too early,
and so for that reason,
I'm out.
Right, absolutely, and I --
I think it's spectacular advice.
Taylor,
I think you're close.
Uh-huh.
You're like a -- you're like
an out-of-tune guitar.
[ laughs ]
You just got to tune it up
a little bit.
Mm.
I'm not seeing
the big jump today.
Sure, sure.
I'm out.
Taylor, I'm an investor
on a very similar product
called game changer
meetings.
Okay.
You go on there.
You want to meet
a supermodel
to show you
how to walk down the runway.
Right.
Anybody can show you
how to walk down the runway,
but if you want a supermodel,
it's $4,000.
HERJAVEC: Wow!
I think your positioning
is absolutely wrong.
Mm.
I think you're working hard
and not smart,
and for those reasons,
I'm out.
GREINER:
In my business on QVC,
I have to convince somebody
in four minutes
why they should pick up
the phone, why they should buy,
and as you've been standing
here, you didn't do that.
I find there's
so much confusion.
I'm out.
All right.
Appreciate it, man.
Thank you.
Darn it.
I don't know if I want some guy
who was in a rock band
coming to my house
to teach my daughter how
to play an instrument.
[ laughs ]
Well, hey, man,
we gave it all we got.
It's their loss.
ROBINSON: Even though
we didn't get a deal today,
I'm encouraged to move forward.
They seemed like they liked me
and they liked the business,
and we're just gonna keep doing
what we do.
NARRATOR: Next into the tank
are two friends
with a unique way
to create your own energy.
Hi.
I'm David Toledo.
And I'm Caleb Light.
Our company is Power Practical,
creators of the Powerpot.
We're seeking
a $250,000 investment
for 10% equity
in our company.
We know that
just about everyone
knows how to boil
a pot of water
and charge their phone,
but what if I told you
you could charge your phone
from a pot of boiling water?
Our first product
is the Powerpot.
It takes fire and water
and makes power
with no moving parts.
It's a great solution
which we use
to generate portable,
on-demand power
because it works day,
night, rain, or shine.
The best part is,
it's super easy to use.
And I'm gonna show you
how easy it is to use.
You simply take
your Powerpot.
You add water to the pot.
You fire up your stove.
You take your regulator cord.
You plug it into the back.
And as you can see,
in a matter of seconds,
you're making power.
Wow.
The Powerpot is
an incredible innovation
that is a simple
cooking vessel
that now doubles as
a mini renewable power plant.
Who wants to join our team
and keep charging?
Pretty cool, guys.
Can we see the packaging?
Very cool.
Yeah, okay.
You don't need to put water
in it, do you?
TOLEDO: You -- you do need
to put water in it.
Why?
So, the Powerpot
is a thermoelectric generator,
which means it takes
a temperature difference
from the bottom
of the pot.
And whatever's inside,
which should be water,
and turns it into electricity
with no moving parts.
So, as the water heats up,
it becomes less efficient
in generating electricity?
Yes. So, as the temperature
difference decreases,
it produces less power.
So, Caleb, how long
would it power something?
The Powerpot output's 5 Watts,
or 1 amp, of current,
so that means 90% of
the USB devices will charge
just as quickly
as at home.
O'LEARY:
Is there anything protected,
or anybody can do this?
So, we filed a patent
in 2010,
and it's been published,
and it's still pending.
I can't even cook a hot dog
in this thing.
[ laughs ]
Like, what's the game plan
size-wise?
So, in terms
of the typical use case
for someone that goes
into the outdoors...
Yeah.
...That's a pot
that's pretty common.
We actually have
larger-style pots.
So, where have you
been selling this set?
So, we initially launched
our company
on a crowd-funding
platform.
Of course.
Which one?
Kickstarter, and --
what did you raise?
We set out to raise 50 grand
in 30 days, and we raised 126.
Okay.
We pre-sold
roughly 1,000 units.
What do you guys want
to do with the money?
So, we want to do
three things.
We want to sell
more product.
We want to get
into more doors,
which we need to hire
a few more people.
Second thing
we want to do is,
we're doing some testing
with some big-box stores,
and so we need to assist
in the sell-through
with some point of sale.
And then the third thing
we want to do is,
we want to continue
to expand our product line.
You're asking for $250,000
for 10%,
and you're valuing
the company at $2.5 million.
Yep.
And you've sold
$300,000 worth of goods.
This year.
Have you got any orders
from outdoor retailers?
Yeah, we are in over 100
different doors right now.
Beyond a niche product,
how big is this market?
Like, what could
your sales be next year?
We're projecting to be
in the range
of about $2 million
next year.
[ laughter ]
But there
are some solar companies
that are doing tens of millions
of dollars of sales every year.
So, when I was a teenager,
I was a camp counselor,
and I used to take
two-week trips without any food.
We'd go out
into the wilderness.
I have very unfond memories
of that time.
[ laughter ]
And...
[ Herjavec laughs ]
...I hate camping today,
and I have a new rule.
Wherever I sleep,
there's a mint on my pillow.
[ laughter ]
So, I have absolutely
no interest in your deal.
I'm out.
All right,
well, thanks, Kevin.
We appreciate your time.
No problem.
JOHN: Unlike Kevin,
I enjoy the great outdoors
a lot, and I know roughing it.
So when I go out and I rough it
with my Range Rover,
my computers,
and my cable TV...
[ Greiner laughs ]
...My masseuse, and
my pop-up McDonald's store,
I really -- I really
understand the value of that,
but I just don't see
the market for that.
This business is too small
for me to invest in.
I'm out.
GREINER: I see you
in an early phase...
LIGHT: Mm-hmm.
...Of this.
I'm not really sure
how big it's gonna go.
So I'm out.
Well, thanks, Lori.
We appreciate it.
Thank you.
Okay, we have two sharks left,
I believe.
Well, unlike the other
three soft and fluffy sharks...
[ laughter ]
...I do love camping,
and I was a boy scout
for many, many years.
Mm-hmm.
I think
it's a beautiful design,
and the form factor
is perfect for camping.
Everything goes in.
It'll fit in your backpack.
But at
a $2.5-million value...
You're asking
for $250,000 for 10%?
Mm-hmm.
I think
you've already priced it
in the size
of that market.
I don't see a way for me
to participate today.
I'm out.
Okay, thanks, Robert.
And then there was one.
[ sighs ]
NARRATOR:
Four sharks are out.
Mark Cuban is Powerpot's
last chance for a deal.
And then there was one.
[ laughs ]
CUBAN: Where do you see
the company in three years?
What other applications
do you see for that?
LIGHT:
The emerging markets?
That's a market that we see
could be a huge benefit
on our side, and --
you mean like
third-world application?
TOLEDO: We have Powerpots
in Uganda with a nonprofit.
They're keeping track
of them,
finding out what people
are using them for.
But just their phones,
right? Just being able to --
that's what we thought
it was gonna be.
It was gonna be phones,
but that ends up
not being the case.
What is the case?
In Uganda, because
they have a fire indoor,
they want lights.
What are you gonna do,
Mark?
The pot's boiling.
I know.
LIGHT: The pot's boiling.
[ Greiner laughs ]
And it's charging.
Guys, I like
what you're doing.
Um...I like
the social aspects of it.
I just get the sense
that you've got
all the pieces you need.
We see tons of value
in bringing someone like you
to the table.
So, closing a round
with you means
we potentially will never have
to raise money again ever.
Since you guys
are smart [laughs]
I'll offer you
250k for 20%.
For 20%?
Yeah.
Ooh!
Well, Mark,
we have investors
that have already put money up
to the table.
We put a tremendous amount
of value in that.
We feel like that would
not be very good for --
so you see no value in all
the stuff you just said
that was so great about Mark?
is that what you're saying?
No, no, no, no.
I just am saying that --
well, you cut
the value in half.
O'LEARY: But a shark brings
more than just money,
and I think you made
reference to that.
Well, we -- we still see
GREINER: Right.
A lot of value
in bringing on Mark.
You don't see that much.
You only see 10% value.
O'LEARY: There's many
venture-capital firms out there.
There's only one Shark Tank.
So what if we did 12% equity
for $250,000,
plus another 3%
of advisor options
and offer a seat
on our board?
You got a deal.
Whoo! Yeah!
Wow.
If it's a good company,
it's a good company.
Congratulations.
Good job.
Mr. Cuban,
we appreciate it.
They even called you
"Mr. Cuban."
I don't like that.
I like "Mark."
Nice job, guys.
Yeah, boy!
[ grunts ]
Whoo!
Try that again.
HERJAVEC: That was
a good one, Mark.
Good kids.
That was
a really good product.
CUBAN:
It's a good company.
I just hate camping
so much.
[ laughs ]
NARRATOR: On the very first
episode of "Shark Tank,"
Tiffany krummins brought
a homemade prototype
of her children's medicine
dispenser, Ava the elephant,
into the tank, and she struck
a deal with Barbara Corcoran.
You know what?
I'd love to take your offer.
We're gonna make money
on this together.
NARRATOR:
Let's see how she's doing now.
Okay, guys, let's make
these a priority.
KRUMMINS: You know,
I really still can't believe
that Barbara took a gamble
on me that first episode.
Five years ago,
I walked into the Shark Tank
as green as it comes.
I'm trying to play hardball.
Can you tell?
Barbara kind of took me
under her wing
and helped me transform my
prototype into a real product.
All of this happened while
I was battling thyroid cancer.
I truly believe that my business
was a great motivator
to fight cancer and beat it.
Today, I am so happy
and thankful to report
that I am still cancer-free.
The biggest thing
that's happened in my business
is a connection with a company
called healthpons.
Healthpons is so important to me
because they have unlimited
resources and connections
with doctors and hospitals.
They have allowed me
to get into doors
that I could not
get into before.
We already have
confirmed purchase orders
for over $6 million in hospitals
and doctors' offices alone.
Patty, I'm offering you
my entire share
in Ava the elephant.
I would like to offer you
230,000 shares...
Wow.
...Of healthpons.
With the stock swap,
I'm becoming a partner
in healthpons,
and healthpons is becoming
a partner in Ava the elephant.
We're taking our best resources
and putting them together.
We can help
put more smiles
on more
sick children's faces.
WOMAN: We are presenting
to you the Phoenix award
for your creation
of Ava the elephant,
which has benefited
the lives
of many children
across the nation.
KRUMMINS:
To be recognized today
for all of my work
with children
and bringing manufacturing
to the United States
is just phenomenal.
KRUMMINS:
My "Shark Tank" experience
has been truly life-changing.
I went from working as a nanny
to providing for my family.
I'm truly touched.
Thank you.
When you first saw me
on the show,
my daughter was 3 months old.
She has literally grown up
in this industry.
It brings me to tears
thinking about how proud I am to
show her that you can do this.
You can follow your dreams.
[ applause ]
My name is Stan Krozel.
This is my partner,
Kevin Ullery.
We're from sugar grove,
Illinois,
and we live
with our dog, Max.
ULLERY: Stan and I met
when we were 25 years old,
and it really was
love at first sight.
He is
very business-oriented.
I'm a lot more laid-back.
Stan's the brains.
I'm the beauty.
I was very successful
in real estate,
but when
the real-estate market crashed,
it changed everything.
And we needed to find
a new business to get into
to bring in the cash flow
we needed.
Watching Stan
have to shut the doors
for the last time
was devastating.
It was the hardest thing
that we've been through
together for sure.
How do you
like these colors?
I think it looks good.
We've always gotten along
very well,
so we thought
it would be fun
to start a new business
venture together.
Our product is unique
because every experience
is one of a kind,
and we're paving the way
to new adventures.
To get this business going,
we risked everything.
We risked
all of our finances.
Even our relationship
was put to the test.
Here's to building
a new future, Stan.
Sounds good.
We've experienced firsthand
the pain of losing a business,
so this new company is our way
of getting back on track.
So, if things don't go our way
in the tank,
this could be the end
of the road for us.
[ train horn honking ]
[ children talking excitedly ]
[ bell ringing ]
Oh, Lord.
Oh. [ chuckles ]
oh, that is so cool.
JOHN: Hey! They got
little people in there!
Hey!
[ laughter ]
[ chuckles ]
Aww.
CHILD: Hey!
Lori, let's hop on.
[ laughs ]
Hi.
CUBAN: Hi.
[ laughter ]
Bye!
Hello, sharks.
My name is Stan Krozel.
And my name
is Kevin Ullery.
We're from Chicago,
Illinois.
Yay.
Our company
is Fun Time Express.
We are seeking
a $125,000 investment
in exchange for a 20% equity
stake in our businesses.
Sharks, we want you to take
a trip down memory lane.
Think back to those days
in your childhood
when mom and dad would take you
along for a trip to the mall
when you were dragged
from store to store,
stuck in an endless loop
of rejection and boredom.
"dad, can I get
some ice cream?"
"no."
"mom, can I go
to the toy store?"
"no, here's some money.
"why don't you ride
the merry-go-round
while I get myself
a new pair of shoes?"
[ snaps fingers ]
and there
you find yourself,
sitting on a dirty,
plastic horse,
going in circles
on a trip to nowhere.
That's the problem.
Most malls offer
the same old attractions.
Well, sharks, we've broken
the confinement barrier.
We want you to relive
your childhood
and imagine what trips
to the mall would've been like
with a ride on...
BOTH: The Fun Time Express!
That's right.
Fun time express
is a trackless train ride
for all ages.
And we travel
through the entire mall,
so it gives dads a chance
to take a break,
moms a chance
to window-shop,
and shopping malls
are just the beginning.
Our trains
are built and equipped
to handle any event
or environment, like parks,
amusement parks, sports arenas,
even private parties.
Thank you, sharks. We are ready
for your questions.
Is this
an existing business?
a brand-new start-up?
We currently have
five operational trains.
Actually, a sixth one
was placed online
a couple of weeks ago.
This will be our lucky
number seven.
Walk us through
how I make money.
Monday through Thursday,
it's like virtually
most retail businesses.
Friday and Saturday,
basically,
we can have
several hundred dollars,
even $500 to $800
on a weekend.
That's it --
500 bucks in two days?
What does it cost?
That sucks!
What -- what is...
Is it a nickel
to ride it?
[ laughs ]
No, it's $3
to ride a train.
What's the capital expenditure
to buy the train?
Each train
is about $37,500.
Believe it or not,
six to eight months
is the expected
projected time
to pay off a train in full
from net proceeds.
HERJAVEC: Stan, do you --
correct, and that's
the beauty about it.
There's limited overhead.
Stan, so, what
do you pay the mall?
Malls are basically
individually negotiated leases.
Last year, what did you gross,
and what was your net?
Well, we started in 2011.
We've sold 31,000 tickets.
So you did about $95,000?
We did about $106,000
in gross revenues.
About $47,000
was net profits.
Okay.
In 2012, we doubled.
We actually went to about
62,000 in ticket sales.
We went to about $216,000
in gross revenues,
and we went to a little over
$80,000 roughly in net profits.
Next year, with all seven
trains fully operational,
we're projecting at selling
over 300,000 tickets.
GREINER: $3 a ride.
I'm just curious where
you picked that number from.
$3 seems
to be the magic number.
In November, December,
like many stores do,
you could boost up
to one ticket for $5,
two for $8,
three for $10,
and we have done that
in one mall.
Yeah, look, you've got
constrained capacity.
You've got 24
or 28 seats, right?
Absolutely.
And so your ability
to change your prices
expands by the traffic
in the mall.
Absolutely.
Sure thing.
So variable pricing
is the wave of the future.
I'm glad
you're on top of it.
But the bigger issue is,
it's not really
a scalable business, right?
It's tough to grow this.
You could add more malls.
Well, of course
you get more malls,
but then the more malls
you get,
the more people you need
to manage them,
the more people
you have to manage,
all the people
you have driving the trains,
maintaining the trains.
Even though I realize
over multiple years,
it might be a nice little income
for an individual operator,
from an investor's perspective
who's looking to get a return
in addition to what
you're looking to get,
that makes it
more difficult,
and so for that reason,
I'm out.
JOHN: You know, I grew up --
I grew up riding trains
a lot as a kid,
but they were the f-trains, so,
you know, I would get on there.
I was flashed by a vagrant,
my pockets would be picked,
and I'd have bedbugs by the time
I'd get off the train.
[ laughter ]
Yeah.
Ew!
Oh, boy.
Ew.
That was the f train --
New York City.
So, I want to believe in this.
But I took my kids on something
like this at the carnival,
right?
By the time I was done,
both of my kids
were playing online poker
on their smartphones.
They couldn't care less.
It's just not a model for me.
I'm out.
We understand.
Thank you for the audience.
We appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
O'LEARY: What every shark
is struggling with
is a scalability
and the actual return.
I mean,
it's -- it's sort of --
you came in too early
is what he's saying.
It's one of these deals
that I'm tempted,
but it's too small.
It just --
but the -- but that's
the idea, is we --
you know, where is the world
domination of the mall?
[ laughter ]
Let's not limit it
to malls.
We can take these anywhere.
That's why we need you.
You know,
I think -- I get it.
It's interesting.
It's small.
The train is small.
The deal is small.
The returns are small.
I like to think big.
Well,
let's think big together.
Big, big, big, big, big, big.
This train can grow.
100 locations.
Basically, if we did absolutely
nothing all next year,
that's $150,000 net profit
that's passive income,
Mr. wonderful.
You love
to invest in stocks.
No, look, I like it.
Think of it that way.
There's a little concern
about economies
in different regions,
but the model basically works.
It's not bad.
It's just small.
HERJAVEC: Here's the great
thing about your business.
You're making a pretty steady
stream of income.
I think this is a great
business for you guys,
but it's too small
for an investor.
I'm out.
Guys, look,
I'm very tempted
because back-of-my-envelope
calculations,
you're making about 20% return
on the capital.
Probably 25%, 30%.
Give us one
of your crazy proposals.
It's just too small.
I'm --
there's small,
and small grows to big.
You started out small, too,
and look where you're at today.
What are you gonna do?
I'm suffering,
I'm suffering!
CUBAN:
You're killing me, smalls!
I'm suffering
listening to you!
Okay, okay, look, guys, it's too
small for Mr. Wonderful.
I'm out.
Thank you
for your consideration.
Oh, my gosh, that train
finally left the station.
[ laughing ] Yeah.
[ laughs ]
I'm thinking about this
'cause I like what you're doing
in that you're bringing
something to the malls
that's different.
You're kind of bringing back
something that's fun for kids,
and parents can do it
with them.
It's like a feel-good,
nice kind of business...
And it is, Lori.
...To have.
Thank you
for saying because --
not -- go ahead.
Well, you know, when Stan first
approached me about this
and said, "well, Kev, we're
gonna drive choo-choo trains
in the mall"...
[ Herjavec laughs ]
...I was a little apprehensive
to say the least.
[ laughs ]
But then once
I went to the mall...
You have to see it
in person to appreciate it.
...And saw it in person,
it's exactly what you said.
There was just such a level
of joy associated with it,
and we were going through
a pretty rough time.
Um...
I just think, you know,
it would be so wonderful to get
one of you guys behind us.
May I say one thing?
We are willing to do
100% return.
Every dollar that we make
from the sale of tickets,
every dollar would go towards
paying that debt in full.
Then thereafter,
you would get 20%.
That's interesting to me.
So, here's my offer.
I'm gonna offer you half,
but I'm gonna need
another shark in with me.
Okay.
I'd like Mr. Wonderful,
my buddy here,
because of connections,
and he fits.
[ sighs ] You're wrestling
with this, man.
Yeah, I am 'cause it's
actually not a bad business.
All right, Stan and Kev,
the offer is this.
You get $125,000,
you have two sharks,
and we are going to get 20%
of the whole business,
and we'll grow this together
with you.
There are some metrics
I want to work on,
I want to tweak with you.
We can make more money
than you're making.
What do you say, guys?
Absolutely,
we would be honored.
We would love to do business
with both of you.
And we want a dining car.
Yes.
All right.
And you will get
your dining car.
[ laughter ]
Thank you.
Fantastic.
Thank you all
for your attention.
It's a good thing
to be doing.
Beautiful presentation.
ULLERY: We will not
let you down.
All right,
let's sell some tickets.
Congrats, guys.
We're gonna sell lots
of tickets, guys.
Thank you so much.
Thank you all
for your audience.
Congratulations.
You bo-bos did
all that thinking,
and you didn't even
negotiate.
No, don't worry.
'cause we're getting
our money back.
[ train horn honking ]
[ laughs ]
[ bell ringing ]
[ laughing ] Yes!
We're excited, America.
We're gonna bring
a trackless train
in every mall in America.
NARRATOR: Next into the tank
is a firefighter
with an invention
to prevent costly damage
for homes and business.
Sharks, I'm Matt Scarpuzzi,
and my company is Quickstop
fire sprinkler tools.
I'm seeking $150,000 in exchange
for 10% equity in my company.
What would you do
if the fire sprinklers
above your head right now
started to pour out
an entire bathtub of water
every other minute?
Now, fire sprinklers
are the best way to save lives
and protect property.
The bad news is, every year
in the United States,
accidental activations
of these sprinkler heads
cause billions of dollars
in water damage.
I'm gonna show you
what an activated sprinkler head
looks like.
I want you to imagine this water
pouring out inside your home
or your business.
What you need is a Quickstop
fire sprinkler tool.
With the Quickstop, you're not
just getting an incredible tool.
You're getting
an insurance policy
that protects
your greatest investments
from expensive water damage.
Sharks, I need your help
to keep that water in the ocean
with you where it belongs
and not in our homes
and our businesses.
Can we see one?
Absolutely. I have samples
that I'll bring to you.
And these are
on sprinkler heads,
so you can actually
use them yourself.
Thank you, Matt.
So, this is something
that you normally carry around
as a fireman?
These are on every truck
in the city that I work for,
and, yes, this is a tool
that we use to shut off...
Thanks, Matt.
...Fire sprinkler heads
when we're called to scene.
HERJAVEC: Matt?
Yes?
Walk me
through the premise.
The fire alarm goes off.
The sprinkler system
goes off.
So then we know
it's a false alarm.
Mm-hmm.
Is the premise
that the building guy
would then go to every sprinkler
and turn it off?
That's one of the myths
about fire sprinklers
is that every sprinkler head
goes off.
Only the head that is nearest
to the heat source or the fire
or the one that gets
accidentally hit goes off.
Really?
So, 90 --
I didn't know that.
Yeah, 90% of the time,
if there is a fire,
one sprinkler head goes off,
and most of the time
when they're accidentally hit,
it's usually one.
Can't the building
just turn the water source off
to that part?
[ chuckles ]
If it was only that easy.
I've been on calls where
it has taken over 45 minutes
for the building engineer
to find the shutoff.
GREINER: Yes,
I've experienced that.
That is hundreds
of thousands of dollars.
So, Matt,
you're gonna have to educate
every single potential buyer
about the merits of this tool.
That is a form
of hell on Earth.
Unless it happens to you,
which I had it happen to me,
and black, sludgy water
comes out.
It's not clear water.
And then when that water
comes out,
it stains and ruins everything,
and it floods out,
so it went down floor
after floor after floor,
flooding all the floors
all the way down.
I've literally seen one
sprinkler head on the 32nd floor
of a high-rise.
By the time we got there,
which we were eight blocks away,
it was down
to the parking garage.
So, is your premise that
individuals would buy this,
or will building managers
buy it?
I mean, who are you
gonna sell this to?
Our goal is to sell it
to the 33,000 fire departments
that are in the United States.
But don't
the fire departments
already have a tool
like this?
No, they don't.
They don't?
I'm not kidding you.
Before I invented this tool,
I would show up,
and I would feel
utterly useless.
So you have no tool
to turn it off?
We would take
wooden door chalks,
and we would hammer them
together...
Really?
...Inside of the opening.
Tell us about the economics
then, right?
What do they cost to make?
What are you gonna
sell them for?
We have sold almost $18,000
in the last six weeks.
Those cost about $25 each
to manufacture.
What do you sell them for?
They sell for $89.95.
Who were you selling to?
Who did you find
was your customer?
We have sold fire departments,
h.o.a.s, building construction
workers, hospitals.
I like products that get sold
into a very narrow market...
Mm-hmm.
...Because it's easy
to capture,
but I'm trying
to get my head around,
are the departments gonna buy
one for every fireman
or just put one
on the truck?
'cause if it's one
on every truck,
it's not that big a market.
Most of what we're selling to
is one on every engine.
However, the fire department
is one little sliver.
The market that we're selling to
is the people who go in
and install these systems
because they knock them off.
Oh, I see.
Homeowners who have had one
go off above them
because they've suffered the
pain of the water coming down.
Is there a patent on it?
This has a utility patent
that was filed back in may,
and we're still waiting
to hear back from that.
And what are you gonna do
with the $150,000?
I need to buy more parts.
We have a couple orders
that are possibly coming forward
in the thousands,
and I don't have that inventory
on hand right now.
Basically, anybody that has
a fire sprinkler system
should have this tool
in their home,
but getting to them is
a whole different problem.
That brings up a great point,
and that's --
no kidding.
SCARPUZZI: I actually have
a second product.
Ah!
Oh.
And this is our home
fire sprinkler kit.
It is designed
for the homeowner.
It is actually a two-piece tool,
and it not only stops
fire sprinklers,
but it stops other plumbing
leaks around your house.
How does it work?
There is a disposable cartridge
that gets loaded into the handle
of the gun.
This is designed to fit
sprinkler heads,
as well as other plumbing.
So, if you have a sink
like I have here
and you have a hose break...
GREINER:
What about a pipe break?
So, you have this hose that's --
that's pouring water out
or a pipe, a faucet, a tap
between 5/16 and an inch, this
gets inserted into the leak.
Goes up inside, and, basically,
you push the handle
of the tool forward,
which expands the balloon
and locks the cartridge
in place.
But that -- that has existed
for quite some time
where I'm from.
What, that tool?
Yeah, where I'm from.
We would -- we would fold
the holes in half
and put a cinder block
on it.
[ laughs ]
And that's it.
No more leak.
So, let's get back to
the sprinkler head over here.
The challenge with this
is really educational.
I wouldn't even know
where to start with this.
That's the challenge.
Yeah.
CUBAN:
That's not a challenge.
JOHN: Really?
O'LEARY: Okay,
what's the solution, Mark?
Wait, but it's a challenge
for me.
You're gonna go door to door
and sell them to each home?
No.
But I think this is --
"hi. I'm Mark Cuban.
I've solved your problem."
hey, I used to go door to door
selling when I was a kid.
I could.
You're gonna start again?
Yeah, why not?
I have absolutely no knowledge
in how
I can help you with this.
You've come up with an ingenious
product, but I'm out.
Thank you.
Appreciate it.
Lori, if there was ever
a QVC product...
[ laughs ]
...This has to be it.
Here's my feeling.
You risk your lives
every day to save us,
and now you're doing something
really admirable
in that you're trying
to create a product
that stops damage
in our homes.
And because I think
this is something needed
and really good,
I'm gonna make you an offer.
But I think there's
a lot of risk in it,
so I'm gonna need
another shark in with me.
So, I'm gonna offer you half,
$75,000.
But I'm gonna want 18%.
So they would get 18%,
as well,
so it would be 36% total.
And I think this should be
a consumer product, as well.
But we need to get
one other shark in.
NARRATOR:
One shark is out.
Lori has made a partial offer
but wants another shark
in on the deal.
So, I'm gonna offer you half,
$75,000.
But I'm gonna want 18%.
So they would get 18%,
as well,
so it would be 36% total.
All right, Matt, so, I think
it's a very clever design,
but I disagree with Lori.
I don't see it as
a large consumer product.
I think you will definitely
sell one
to every fire department,
but until you came
out here today,
I didn't realize that you
get false alarms with them.
So I don't see a self-evident
consumer market.
The training challenge is
tremendous to educate people.
I'm out.
Thank you.
Appreciate it.
GREINER:
I'm going to clarify.
For me to be invested,
it's the whole kit and caboodle.
It's this
for the sprinkler heads.
It's that for leaking pipes.
It's everything.
Yes.
And --
and it's actually
one more thing.
Oh, great, bring it on.
So, wait, there's more.
Firefighters climb ladders
all day long.
The average person doesn't,
and in order to get up
to the sprinkler head,
how do they get up there
without climbing a ladder?
So, what I did...
Was, I designed a pole,
and the pole actually gets...
[ laughter ]
...The Quickstop talon
into the pole.
It telescopes out over 12 feet,
and anybody like a homeowner
or a maintenance worker
can operate.
That, I think, is brilliant
because you get it
[snaps fingers] fast.
When do you have time
to work?
[ laughs ]
My brain --
You're designing things
all day.
I like your mind.
My brain is always moving.
O'LEARY: Let me declare
my position on this.
Because, you know, I see
the merits of the product,
but I do not see the path
to market.
I think
it's a very challenging one.
The only way
I would do the deal
and be the other $75,000
in Lori's scenario
is if I get 25%.
She can stay at 18%,
but I think the challenge...
[ laughs ]
...Is really horrific.
That's one hell of a fire
you're gonna have to put out.
I would encourage Lori
to go to 25%,
and the partnership
would get 50%...
Oh, Lord.
...Which is what
I think it deserves.
I don't care what Mr. Cuban
says about this.
I think the challenge here
is brutal,
and if you want to step in
and take my $75,000
at a different price,
go ahead and do it.
But I want 25% because
this is not a company.
It's a product.
I do appreciate that offer,
and I agree with part
of what you're saying,
but I do own a company,
and we are starting to establish
lines of distribution.
Matt,
let me ask a question.
Why not, given
the value proposition
that you've discussed
and the hundreds of thousands,
if not millions, of dollars
that can be saved,
why $89?
Why not $299?
Why not $499?
That's a great question.
As a new product,
I put that $89.95 out there
to get a feel for the market,
and you're absolutely right.
We have not had anybody
kick at our price.
People are paying $200
for a sprinkler tool that
can't do what mine does.
Right, so why aren't you
charging $299?
'cause it solves
all your problems.
Because I'm a fireman
and I design tools
and that's what I'm good at.
Therein lies the problem.
And I'm learning this.
JOHN: That's the operator
problem we're talking about.
SCARPUZZI: And I'm learning
this new thing.
O'LEARY: That's why
I want to be commensurate
with the risk inherent here.
the problem is,
you don't have a company.
You're an inventor.
And you have a full-time job
and a full-time obligation,
and so whoever the partner is,
if you get a partner,
is gonna be responsible
for that other side.
So my point is,
I'm not looking to have
to insert that much manpower
to help develop a company.
So my ask
is not unreasonable.
You can decide on that,
but to answer the question,
I'm out.
Thank you.
HERJAVEC: Mark's out.
Damon's out.
Kevin made you an offer --
$75,000 for 25%.
If Lori goes in with him,
you're giving up 50% of your
business to get your $150,000.
You got to make
a decision here.
Well, Lori, she hasn't clarified
where she stands. She dropped --
yeah, Lori,
are you in on that?
I would like you, Kevin,
to go in with me...
O'LEARY: Right.
...Because
this is good product.
Would you go 40%?
No.
20%/20%?
No,
it's a partnership 50/50.
Half the work is here.
That's the way
I look at it.
The immense amount of work
it's gonna take
to actually bring this
to market,
it's weighing
on my shoulders now.
Lori, Kevin's firm --
$75,000 for 25%.
What are you --
what are you doing?
Are you in on that deal?
Yes, but it doesn't sound
like he's in on that.
All right.
We don't know,
so the offer
on the table right now
to clarify it,
you get two sharks.
Each of them want 25%
because of the weight of work
ahead of us.
I-I do understand the deal.
I thank you, and I cannot do 50%
of my business at this time.
CUBAN: Thank you.
Thank you.
Great idea.
Sorry, it's a great idea.
You're gonna be fine,
Matt.
And I really wish you
good luck.
Thanks for your time.
I appreciate it.
CUBAN:
It's a good product.
I think it's an important
and good product,
but I know what we would have
to put into it.
If he raises the price
to $200 or more,
he'll sell a million dollars
worth of product.
HERJAVEC: I agree.
I understand there's a lot
of work that needs to be done
moving forward,
but I anticipate doing that,
and I will take help,
but I just couldn't do 50%.
It's just too much.